The joe rogan experience.
So sweat this dude,
this guy,
the EPA is highest paid employee in a leading expert in climate change,
deserves to go to prison for at least 30 months for lying to his bosses and
saying that he was a CIA spy working in Pakistan so that he could avoid doing
his real job,
says the federal prosecutors.
So the dude was,
how slick is this cat?
He tells his people at the fucking he,
he goes,
he's works for the EPA,
the highest paid climate expert,
and they go,
well,
we want you to do a lot of studies on climate change.
Like,
listen,
I would love to,
I work for the CIA protecting America.
Meanwhile,
he was just making it up,
but he did it for the longest time.
Like this guy built them out of $1 million over a decade.
I say more power to them.
There's a grift in the system.
Fuck him.
Use it.
Well again,
it's like it's more in competence than it is anything.
It's more human Horesh behavior.
It's greed than it is anything.
That's guys that work example that I have to work for.
The CIA.
What can I tell you?
Cause you imagine the answer town halls,
you have to just invent that you're a CIA operative.
How many fake CIA operatives out there?
Like dudes are trying to impress chicks and it's amazing,
especially with homeland,
it's probably jumped up quite a bit.
Can you prove to us that you're seeing,
I would love to,
but it's top secret would have to have you.
You would have to be sequestered.
That's the thing.
Look,
I can't,
I'm working for the,
I'm trying to save America.
I know.
It looks like I'm on Facebook 23 hours a day.
But uh,
yeah,
they check his cell phone and like,
dude,
your texting like 20 different chicks.
What's going on man?
You were really working on climate change.
It was just getting mad cash.
Just bawling every night.
Going to strip clubs for all parties of his house.
Uh,
it's a lot of youporn but you porn is actually a front for a CIA websites.
So we're making sure that the really dark stuff does.
I watched the,
you know,
the Aina,
we have to allow a certain amount.
I am horrified by the gaping but we have to allow a certain amount.
If we don't allow it,
it's then we're going to lose a lot of the people that would be with us against
this child.
My job to measure the diameter of the gate because if it gets beyond a certain
point,
if we start getting ostrich like we've got to cancel the program.
If I was poor and starving I would and some guy's driving a car worth 250 grand.
I would take it they tore and starving or are they just pour?
I would be,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be starving.
Yeah,
you'd have to be starving a lot.
Most people are just poor.
The poor and starving number's pretty small.
I think I wouldn't take it but I would definitely take a shit on your hood cause
I,
I just want to fuck your shit up but I don't want to steal.
Why be a hater like that?
Why shouldn't I Mansa the guy works so hard to get a nice car and he decides to
keep it in the neighborhood.
And what do you do your shit on it or brings me no enjoyment but my shit on that
hood is brings oh well that's cause you got to hate her mentality.
He should give you enjoyment because she should give you hope.
You should look at that and say look,
this asshole can make that money.
What's,
why is he better than me?
He's not.
So this is inspiration.
Use it for fuel.
Go on and get your own car.
No
car.
All you're going to think about is,
man,
I hope I don't have a car like this is some asshole like me is going to come
along and shit on it.
No.
Would be like I can't wait until the day there's some asshole like me that shits
on my car when I had the cause when you have that,
I'm glad you mad,
mad,
mad enough that someone steps on your hood,
dense your fucking hood in and shits on it.
That is just rude,
disrespectful property and you can't sell that anytime a kid in America and when
I buy a car nut,
I'm just going to expect that someone,
when they will shit on this hood,
they like the,
I listen to Joe Rogan,
I'm going to go find his car and shit on him.
Oh,
that is so rude.
Leave you put that out there because it's going to come back and it's going to
land right in your fucking dashboard.
Someone's going to take your windshield out video now,
but shit,
they got to punch a hole straight three dashboard or through or through
windshield so they can shit directly onto your dashboard.
How dare you?
How dare you even think like that for decker,
sunroof,
Shin.
Even the more pro move.
Yeah,
it.
Well,
it really,
if you want to shit in your own hand,
then smear it in that upper part where you can never clean it out.
That's what I'm saying.
If you want to really fuck up a guy's car,
but why would you do then man entered the runny,
that's bad energy.
You till you're doing well.
You don't need to do this.
You're a successful man.
It can't be hating on some dude with a Bentley.
This is ridiculous.
It's a shitty car.
It's gonna break down in them anyway.
It's going to leave them on the side of the highway.
I've got a friend who has a Rolls Royce.
It breaks,
breaks,
breaks all the time.
Things go wrong,
AC gets stuck on this fucking thing goes wrong.
Radio doesn't work.
This speakers out,
it's a fucking Rolls Royce and it doesn't make sense.
The brakes,
the brakes come by like,
you know on Lincoln you can buy these sort of old like,
you know,
Shit Brown,
seventies rollers for like five grand and every time I go to Vegas I'm like,
I'm going to come back with a brick or two and just buy a shit brown roller and
get like a punk kid with a safety pin through his neck or [inaudible] kid to
just drive me around town.
We're all up to the bars and my Shit Brown,
77 Rolls Royce and be like,
I am I late for the party and you know,
and just have this kid,
you know,
facial tattoos be my driver.
That's not a bad move.
It's make people uncomfortable.
And that wasn't shit on that hood.
If that kid was driving,
you would let that slide like live.
Well you wouldn't shit on the hood of a 77 year old car and then 1977 car.
Anyway,
that car,
I would respect that whip.
I think I'm going to go to track suits and fanny packs.
I'll do it.
I think I'm going to commit,
I'm for the tracks.
Track suit and fanny pack is my new look for life.
I think,
uh,
my body will appreciate it.
It's very light relaxing.
Let's find some good tracksuits Brian and change that to our new wardrobe.
Show you the ones that I want to live in California,
man.
Or you need to wear thermals and shed on need layers of goose down.
I can get by with a track suit and a fanny pack.
I want to be put,
I want to be part of your crew.
I don't feel like it started own tracks.
What kind of sneakers should we where we definitely gotta wear Pumas are Adidas
I'm saying.
Yeah,
whatever the track suit is.
Here's the shoes that a six dozer.
Good.
That's a good choice Brian.
That's a good choice.
That's a comfortable shoe too.
Yup.
And if you're wearing like a blue track suit with some white stripes,
that will fit nicely.
If we learn anything from fat James,
it's tracksuits and a six.
No doubt about it.
Rest in peace.
Fred James.
Yeah.
Tracksuits and [inaudible].
I haven't had a track suit since I was probably 19 was the last time you had an
actual legit traction?
I got one when I was like 28 cause one of the,
I was going out with this girl.
I want her to try to pull it off like we're talking about now.
Yeah,
she worked at a echo.
Do you know that that Mark Echo that clothing line.
She worked there and I'm like give me one of these tracksuits right.
And I tried it for like a week and I just couldn't keep it up,
you know,
track suit.
I couldn't commit because,
put it that way.
I didn't have a crew.
Yeah,
ever.
Readies weren't ready yet.
You gotta have some other people around you that also work so everybody doesn't
give a fuck together,
you know,
because it's just you on your own out there in the wilderness of life,
being judged by your fashion choices anywhere to fucking tracksuit.
And you see a girl outside of a place where a girl,
if you were dressed like this,
she'd be like,
Oh,
oh,
your mat fold tron,
standup comedian.
But she sees you and why are you wearing a track suit?
The,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
I just like being casual and I like dressing like a moron.
Is it?
They don't buy that and moron.
They don't buy it.
Is it a more on thing or is it a comfortable thing?
Are we the morons full charge?
I know I'm the moron with our zippers to get our dicks are belts.
When we could just have a simple drawstring,
easy access.
We've got to start smoking cigars too.
Let's do it.
It's a little old back.
A little bit of organized crime.
Bruce Lee,
Bruce Lee on that type of track suit the same way Hitler on the mustache.
Yeah.
You can't wear that without people thinking that you're Bruce Lee,
Bruce Lee,
and her many more people than him to see like this one.
Nothing.
You could wear that no problem.
But that game of death one,
no,
Bruce Lee owns that.
That's,
that's his.
You can't wear that.
You can't wear a yellow jumpsuit.
It'd be embarrassing to wear a jumpsuit and like a break dance competition
breaks out and then you got nothing.
You get nothing.
You're just kind of inching away quietly.
Oh.